merci merci mon cherothman secrétaire
général
adjoint de notre famille politique qui a
en charge cette question essentielle
importante qui nous réunit qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui
celle de la formation et au travers la
formation
des cadres de notre mouvement que vous
représentez de la Fabrique d'idées de
conviction qui repose naturellement sur
nos valeurs et qui doivent être portées
partout dans nos fédérations et demain
dans les combats électoraux dont vous
serez je l'espère les acteurs pour faire
en sorte que nos idées trouvent une
concrétisation très forte dans toutes
les formations politiques
la formation et le préalable à la
victoire sans formation sans
vertébrale idéologique on ne peut rien
faire c'est cette idée de base qui nous
a mobilisé lorsque j'ai pris la
présidence de notre famille politique
pour nous réorganiser pour faire que
nous puissions avec cet académie Georges
Mendel fondé cette démarche de
reconstruction qui va prendre du temps
bien entendu mais qui doit et quand je
vous vois c'est une forme de de
satisfaction d'abord parce que vous êtes
tous jeunes
et il n'y a pas d'exception vous êtes
volontaire vous êtes déterminé vous êtes
animé par des convictions solides et
vous voulez que ces convictions comme
moi ces convictions elles investissent
demain les plus hauts sommets de l'État
n'ont pas pour nous faire plaisir quoi
que ça peut être un objectif qu'on ne
rejettera pas mais pour redresser un
pays qui en a bien besoin un pays qui
aujourd'hui est confronté à des
difficultés de plus en plus fortes quel
que soit la communication
habile
abondante du pouvoir nous sommes dans un
pays confronté au risque à la menace du
déclin du déclassement d'une forme de
disparition progressive du concert des
plus grandes nations du monde voilà ce
qui nous guide c'est
s'opposer à la banalisation la France ce
n'est pas un pays banal la France c'est
pas une puissance moyenne la France est
une grande puissance qui a un message
universel apporté qui vient du fond des
âges et qui a vocation à redevenir le
phare d'une pensée
contemporaine reposant sur des valeurs
de liberté qui nous ont toujours guidés
aujourd'hui
très loin on en est très loin quand on
voit à la fois les paramètres
économiques qui signent un bilan
particulièrement dégradé
le record
des prélèvements obligatoires le record
des dépenses publiques des déficits
publics mais aussi commerciaux parmi les
plus élevés au monde une dette qui
dépasse les 3000 milliards d'euros donc
on voit bien que ce tableau des
paramètres économiques et
macroéconomiques essentiel et quand même
très éloigné des bilans
d'autosatisfaction que l'on entend et
que l'on a reçu pendant des heures
entières d'ailleurs dans la rencontre de
Saint-Denis la réalité elle est là et
elle est préoccupante elle est
inquiétante on doit y apporter des
réponses et on y apportera des réponses
que par un projet construit bâti
courageux équilibré responsable qui dit
la vérité aux Français qui s'éloignent
de toute forme de démagogie comme on
peut l'entendre
sur une partie de l'échiquier politique
voilà la situation la gravité de la
situation impose de la vérité et cette
situation il faut la voir il faut la
regarder il faut la connaître il faut
l'apporter la préhender
et c'est aussi le rôle et les moments de
cette de ces deux journées de formation
nous avons des paramètres
que ce soit en matière de sécurité que
ce soit en matière d'immigration qui
sont tout autant dégradées sans parler
de la perte d'influence internationale
de notre nation et de façon dramatique
depuis quelques jours de façon accélérée
sur le continent africain donc on voit
bien qu'il y a une situation dégradée on
voit bien que on ne peut pas laisser non
plus le destin de notre pays dans des
chemins sur des chemins
d'irresponsabilités de démagogie et
qu'il y a donc une ligne possible c'est
celle que nous incarnons parce que elle
repose sur des idées fort solide sur de
la crédibilité sur de l'expérience sur
de la compétence sur une histoire
à nous maintenant de la portée vous me
direz qu'on en est loin sans doute mais
l'objectif il est tracé et ces journées
de formation sont autant de petites
pierres ou de briques que l'on va tracer
que l'on va
additionner que l'on va imbriquer pour
redresser cette pour redresser cette
situation et pour au fil des mois qui
avancent dessiner un projet cohérent et
un projet qui pourra parce que des
projets on en a souvent fait ils ont été
sûrement les meilleurs mais on n'a pas
été les meilleurs pour les diffuser pour
les porter pour les communiquer donc
c'est aussi cela il faut qu'on bâtisse
le projet le plus crédible
et dans ces journées nous aurons vous
aurez des débats des échanges avec des
spécialistes
particulièrement aiguisées que ce soit
sur l'économie que ce soit sur les
institutions que ce soit sur les
questions de décentralisation mais le
meilleur projet qui soit si on n'a pas
la compétence la capacité
pour le porter au-delà de nos murs ça ne
peut pas fonctionner donc c'est pour ça
que nous aurons aussi dans ces journées
des modules qui sont tournés beaucoup
sur la connaissance de l'opinion
notamment avec des sondeurs mais aussi
sur la communication politique pour
pouvoir
s'adapter aujourd'hui plus encore au
défi de demain notamment à ceux de
l'intelligence artificielle qu'on doit
s'approprier
qui doivent nous porter nous permettre
nous autoriser
de porter ce message alors merci d'avoir
avec vos fédérations répondues à notre
invitation c'est la deuxième session de
cet académie Georges Mandel qui a vu le
jour au printemps dernier pourquoi
Georges Mendel parce que
c'est un nom qui honore la droite
c'est un nom qui honore la droite il fut
un des plus proches collaborateurs de
Clémenceau qui
porte aussi une certaine idée de la
République du courage de la combativité
et Mandel fut une voix éclairée dans une
période qui ne l'a pas été et qui nous a
conduit à la débâcle et au désastre dans
l'entre-deux-guerres il porta une voie
de courage une voix de lucidité une voix
de combativité pour s'élever contre les
errements qui est qui allait nous
conduire à la défaite et qu'il avait
mesuré qu'il avait appréhendé et puis il
fut
ministre dans le dernier gouvernement
rénaux avec avec de Gaulle
et il fut là aussi immédiatement instant
tétément engagé dans un parcours
d'honneur il refusa la
honte de la collaboration bien sûr il
refusa l'armistice il appela la
poursuite des combats comme De Gaulle
immédiatement et il en fut il en paya le
prix au prix fort avec
l'arrestation les procès la déportation
jusqu'à son exécution dans la forêt de
Fontainebleau en juillet en juillet 44
donc cette figure demandait elle est
importante pour exprimer ce visage de la
lucidité de l'anticipation du courage de
la combativité du refus du déclin du
refus de la démission
du refus du nom du renoncement pour ça
que j'ai
nous avons voulu ensemble qui est cette
académie porta le nom de de George
Mendel ses qualités quelque part dans
des temps éminemment plus troublés mais
ces qualités nous en aurons besoin pour
retrouver ce chemin de victoire que
j'appelais de mes vœux il y a quelques
instants pour que notre pays tout
simplement retrouve son rang et sa place
merci à tous ceux qui qui sont associés
autour d'hautman Nasro
sous la direction de Basile fanier qui
dirige nos fédérations et que je
remercie très vivement parce que c'est
un gros travail pour organiser ces
sessions et il a été à la hauteur de la
mission qu'on lui a confié avec l'équipe
dirigeante
[Applaudissements]
vous aurez aujourd'hui un beau programme
et je salue déjà
nos amis parlementaires qui sont ici
d'abord je salue aussi le président de
l'uni Olivier Vial qui est ici parce que
c'est important l'unique aussi ça a
toujours été un mouvement très proche de
nous et je souhaite qu'il le reste plus
encore parce que nous avons besoin il y
en a aujourd'hui au-delà de la boutade
il y a beaucoup de jeunes il y a
beaucoup d'étudiants et ce sont aussi
des enjeux pour nous essentiels il faut
que l'on réinvestisse fortement plus
fortement ce terrain des idées on l'a un
peu perdu
pas totalement parce qu'elle combat et
l'uni marque des points mais on voit
l'évolution de l'université française
les menaces qui pèsent sur elles
l'infiltration du walkies de
l'intolérance d'une extrême gauche
radicale qui prend le pouvoir dans les
universités qui menacent la liberté de
conscience d'expression et qui est sans
doute un des plus grands dangers qui
pèsent sur notre démocratie parce que
c'est ces personnes sont animées par une
intolérance totale par un obscurantisme
qui a pour germe le commutotarisme la
complaisance avec l'islamisme le
woquisme et des dérives qui n'ont que
pour objectif de nous insérer dans dans
un régime qui ne serait plus un régime
de liberté donc il y a ce combat
idéologique que l'on doit conduire et je
profite de la présence d'Olivier pour
lui dire tout le monde soutient et toute
la nécessité aussi qu'on renoue ce lien
historique avec avec l'uni et ce lien
privilégié je dirais presque exclusif
alors c'est déjà notre débat mais que
l'on veut en tout cas que je souhaite
entretenir merci à nos à nos
parlementaires
merci à nos à nos élus et à nos à nos
parlementaires qui sont qui sont ici ce
matin
Catherine Dumas Marie-Christine Chauvin
Francis piner Frédéric Pechenard qui
nous font Alexandra bourquiau
fondamentatrice avec
Othman qui nous font l'amitié d'être là
et puis pour conclure et pour ne pas
prendre trop de temps parce que vous
êtes venus écouter des intervenants de
très grande qualité je voudrais
collectivement et individuellement les
remercier on a aujourd'hui et demain
donc sur ces deux journées de formation
réunies des grandes voies des grandes
signatures des personnes qui dans leur
domaine de référence font autorité
conjugue compétences expertise
professionnalisme vision que ce soit
dans le domaine de l'économie de
l'entreprise de l'Université des de la
communication politique de l'étude de
l'opinion et je veux les citer vous
allez écouter dans quelques instants
Renaud Girard qui est grand reporter de
guerre et qui est un éditorialiste
reconnu dans le Figaro merci à Renaud
d'être ici on suit son analyse
géopolitique avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'intérêt dans un moment où on a besoin
là aussi de clarté de lucidité on est
dans un monde mouvant
l'Europe est aujourd'hui en serré dans
une guerre des blocs qui opposent la
Chine et les États-Unis et on voit bien
que notre influence ne cesse de décliner
et que en Europe
l'influence de la France
ne cesse aussi de décliner donc il y a
des enjeux qui préoccupent nos
concitoyens légitimement et qui portent
en eux quelque part de notre avenir et
il est important de mieux les saisir et
de mieux les avoir aussi à l'esprit nous
parlerons d'économie avec Yves Perrier
qui préside le conseil d'administration
du Groupe Edmond de Rothschild qui
dirigeait le fond à Mundi jusque
quelques mois et qui a été aussi le
directeur financier de la Société
Générale qui nous dressera j’évoquer
tout à l'heure quelque paramètres
macroéconomiques aussi un état des lieux
sur la situation économique de notre
pays nous évoquerons façon plus
politique l'avenir de la droite en
général avec Laetitia stroogona qui est
essayiste et
rédactrice en chef du point nous
parlerons décentralisation et
institutions avec Benjamin Mor
qui est maître de conférence en droit
public Assas avec Pierre Merin qui est
professeur d'histoire contemporain
contemporaine Panthéon Sorbonne
voilà pierre vermeerin c'est quelqu'un
qui est engagé avec beaucoup de courage
contre les thèses des coloniales islamo
gauchistes dans l'université et
j'évoquais tout à l'heure cette
université menacée et a bien des égards
gangrenés par ces idéologies et Pierre
vermein est un professeur d'université
courageux qui s'est élevé contre ces
dérives nous l'écouterons avec intérêt
nous accueillerons également Franck
l'ouvrier maire de La Baule qui parlera
de communication politique il a été vous
le savez le conseiller en communication
de Nicolas Sarkozy sous la présidence de
Nicolas Sarkozy de 2007 à 2012
à l'Elysée nous évoquerons également je
les disais tout à l'heure un des défis
majeurs qui est devant nous et qui peut
être peu porté en soi à la fois le
meilleur avec un progrès technologique
et humain important mais aussi avec des
menaces parce que faudrait pas que
l'intelligence artificielle
se transforme dans une arme contre
l'humanité elle-même nous parlerons
d'intelligence artificielle avec le
docteur Laurent Alexandre qui que vous
connaissez bien et qui est intervient
fréquemment sur les médias sur ces
thématiques nous parlerons
étude de l'opinion avec Frédéric Daby le
directeur général de l'Ifop
et nous parlerons également de
de ces questions liées à aux sciences de
l'information avec Arnaud Mercier
professeur à Paris à Assas qui
développeront les questions relatives
aux enquêtes au sondages tandis que
Philippe Bluetooth avocat en droit
public et électoral vous évoquera les
questions juridiques relatives aux
élections ça c'est important aussi parce
que si vous êtes là c'est aussi parce
que vous avez envie de vous engager
et moi je veux que cet engagement il est
une concrétisation concrète vous devez
être demain
les candidats nos candidats aux
élections municipales notamment c'est
s'approche très vite 2026 et il faut que
vous structuriez et je souhaite aussi je
le dis qu'au-delà de ces rencontres à
Paris il y ait des formations
déconcentrées sur les territoires dans
les fédérations et que nous ayons une
orientation on va la mettre en oeuvre
très très vite tourné vers la formation
des candidats
il faut qu'on les détecte faut qu'on
leur donne envie d'y aller il faut qu'on
renouvelle aussi des cadres et nous y
arriverons aussi si vous êtes accompagné
et si on peut vous offrir des cadres à
la fois en communication à la fois sur
le juridique sur la préparation des
élections qui seront clairement pour vos
futurs campagnes en tout cas je vous le
souhaite et je l'espère
nous parlerons de l'état des
institutions avec Olivier beau
professeur en droit public Assas qui
dirige l'Institut Michel Viller pour la
culture juridique et la philosophie du
droit nous parlerons également d'un
enjeu majeur majeur celui de
l'environnement de l'écologie que nous
devons pas nous ne devons pas laisser le
monopole à l'extrême gauche nous en
parlerons avec Yves roucotte qui
a écrit des ouvrages qui font référence
en la matière qui est professeur des
universités sur l'immigration nous
entendrons le préfet Michel Aubouin
accompagné de Nicolas Monti de Maxime et
Marc qui sont tous les trois
co-fondateurs de l'Observatoire de
l'immigration qui aujourd'hui
apporte une vision différente de la doxa
officielle sur l'immigration est une
chance pour notre nation et qui donne
les vrais chiffres et qui ont révélé des
vérités qui sont bonnes à entendre à
dire et à défendre
nous
entendrons également Thierry Rambaud et
frédéric Rouvillois qui sont tous deux
professeurs de droit à l'université
Paris Cité qui concluront aujourd'hui et
qui conclurant ses journées en vous
parlant du référendum
référendum
on en a beaucoup parlé dans l'actualité
c'est une des propositions que j'ai
porté devant le président de la
République
lors de
l'échange ou de la séance de
communication plutôt qui a eu lieu à
Saint-Denis la semaine dernière
cette question du référendum vous savez
qu'elle est au coeur hautement d'en
parler tout à l'heure du projet que nous
avons déposé avec
Bruno Retailleau avec Olivier marlex
dans les mêmes termes à la fois
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat pour
porter une réforme constitutionnelle au
travers l'activation de l'article 89 de
notre Constitution une réforme
constitutionnelle qui permet de répondre
aux grands défis migratoires notamment
en portant le principe que l'asile ne
doit plus être examinée à l'intérieur de
nos frontières mais à l'extérieur ce qui
évitera aujourd'hui l'entrée de 156 000
demandeurs d'asile dont l'année dernière
110 000 se sont vus refuser le noble
statut de réfugiés donc qui ont utilisé
des voyelles pour rentrer légalement
dans notre pays et pour y demeurer de
façon quasi définitive nous porterons
aussi dans cette réforme
constitutionnelle le principe de plafond
migratoire votez chaque année par le
Parlement et qui s'imposerait et c'est
pour cela que nous avons la nécessité
que ce point figure demain dans la
Constitution qui s'imposerait à toutes
les normes supranationales ou
jurisprudentielle qui aujourd'hui font
obstacle à toutes volonté législatives
de réguler les migrations donc cette
question du référendum
que ce soit au travers de l'article 11
et de sa déclinaison sur le référendum
d'initiative
site populaire tel qu'il est prévu dans
la constitution ou que ça soit le
référendum
issu de la procédure de révision
constitutionnelle de l'article 89 il y
en a deux aujourd'hui j'ai évoqué lors
de notre rentrée politique à Nice dans
les Alpes-Maritimes au Cannet
précisément dans notre intervention le
fait que pour donner de la crédibilité à
une parole publique qui en marquent
cruellement désormais mais pour aussi
donner la confiance aux électeurs
auxquels on veut
désormais nous adresser pour leur dire
vous nous avez quitté parce que on vous
a sans doute déçu par le passé
aujourd'hui on a le meilleur projet mais
vous doutez de sa mise en oeuvre si on
arrive aux responsabilités donc la
meilleure garantie que ce projet qui est
le meilleur incontestablement et qui est
porté par les personnalités qui ont le
plus d'expertise et de compétences
qu'il soit demain appliquer si on arrive
au pouvoir grâce à vous c'est que vous
le décidiez vous-même par le biais de
référendum très précis qui serait
préalablement annoncé donc le référendum
doit redevenir un outil de gouvernance
et un outil qui recoud le lien distendu
entre les Français et ceux qui les
gouvernent donc cette question du
référendum nous avons voulu la placer au
cœur aussi de ces journées et enfin nous
aurons aussi la chance d'avoir
l'éclairage d'Henri Guaino qu'on ne plus
qui est une grande voie avec des
convictions
fortes je les partages pas forcément
toutes enfin le débat et bienvenue il
est important et Henri Guaino qui a été
conseillé spécial de Nicolas Sarkozy
porte aussi
en lui cette
vision
je vous rappelle qu'il avait été
notamment le promoteur de l'Union pour
la Méditerranée
idée que j'ai reçu mise au président de
la République la semaine dernière qui
est d'ailleurs dans dans le relevé des
conclusions pour renouer le dialogue
entre les deux rives de la Méditerranée
ce qui doit être aussi une réponse
aux grands défis migratoires qui est
devant nous parce que ce qui nous attend
est naturellement pire que ce que nous
avons déjà subi et nous avons besoin de
ce lien entre les deux rives de la
Méditerranée et Henri avait eu cette
vision extraordinaire de porter cette
Union pour la Méditerranée cette idée
elle a été poursuivie elle a été
abandonnée après le départ de Nicolas
Sarkozy je crois qu'il faut aujourd'hui
la remettre au goût du jour voilà un
programme vous le voyez danse riche de
qualité nous allons le poursuivre le
développer sur les territoires ici le
réédité le réitérer en tout cas du fond
du coeur merci de votre présence de
votre mobilisation de votre
participation et de croire tout
simplement à l'avenir de notre partie
politique de notre famille politique
parce que au-delà nous croyons tous que
le déclin de la France n'est pas
un chemin inéluctable et que notre
mission notre vocation et ce pourquoi
nous allons nous battre et en tout cas
moi avec toutes mes forces et toute ma
détermination c'est le redressement
d'une nation qui doit à nouveau
continuer à éclairer le monde merci
beaucoup
bon travaux
[Applaudissements]